[Music]
the pandemic turned our lives upside
down altering the way we work and play
even where we live
[Music]
hello hello
welcome to my humble about
while many were looking for more space
william mansur decided to downsize
trading his shared town home for an
eight meter houseboat i love it i love
sailing and i love the community that's
built around it
though he admits the living quarters are
cramped
mansur is a computer programmer last
year his company closed its offices
forcing employees to work remotely
permanently the move celebrated by some
left mansur in a tight spot
it's easy to get claustrophobic and so i
needed to find a space where i could
work
he found a solution just a short bike
ride away at this downtown toronto
office building
mansur now pays 300 a month for a desk
at this co-working space
it's worth it he says for the extra
legroom and the community he missed
being around other people
and he's not alone
[Music]
definitely there's a lot of loneliness
but there's also
you know loneliness in a crowded house
for a lot of people too just prior to
the pandemic meredith garrettson
launched this vancouver co-working space
for women i kind of just fell in love
with the idea of having a space with
other women that were building their
businesses and we could kind of share in
that experience
then during the pandemic garrison's
personal life took a turn her marriage
fell apart her mother was diagnosed with
dementia
and her co-working colleagues became a
lifeline
i already had this network that i was
able to
turn into and i didn't tell everybody
right away
but eventually they became my safety net
and so
in a way that i thought that i was
building something for somebody else it
turns out i really benefited quite a bit
i think as people we naturally crave
social interaction i think that's the
reason we're seeing renewed interest in
these co-working spaces
[Music]
andrew au is a work culture consultant
we're going to keep this
entertaining as well as educational
his business is helping other businesses
adopt better ways of working
the pandemic has changed business i'd
say that the past decade
the focus has been on customer
experience you know predicting customer
needs personalizing the customer
experience but i think what's happening
now is the pendulum has swung to
employee experience
what do employees need
at the start of this year about a third
of canadians worked mostly at home
compared with just four percent a few
years ago
[Music]
for many including al that meant less
time commuting and more spent with his
family
but working from home surrounded by
children and chores has its own
challenges
working from home can be chaotic
and so that's why we wanted to give
employees a space to kind of get away
from that
all right jeff welcome to the intercept
cottage
so oww's company intercept purchased
this lakefront condo in cottage country
about an hour's drive north of toronto
it's available to his employees for free
as a space to work
you can have your laptop you could be
sitting at the beach club
and then you kind of look out and this
is your scene
al points to a global survey that
recently found three quarters of workers
prefer a flexible hybrid model a
combination of working from home and the
office or somewhere else that's what
they're demanding so as much as we are
in a technology race
we are in a talent race and if we want
to win that race
we need to offer flexibility and choice
to to employees
flexibility can also boost productivity
research has found remote workers
typically work longer are more
productive and less likely to quit
but what about those who can't work from
home or require close collaboration with
teammates a lot of us have spent the
pandemic sitting at our desks
interacting with our colleagues over
zoom but some emerging technology is now
altering that reality
[Music]
for 40 years ontario aerospace company
mda has trained astronauts to operate
the canadarm the canadian made robotic
arms used on space shuttles and the
international space station but when the
pandemic hit the team was grounded
unable to conduct its training
that is until jessa marie zabala and her
team had an idea that seemed out of this
world i
spend my meetings in space
through virtual reality
prior to the pandemic the engineer had
experimented with augmented reality
headsets they project holograms across a
physical space
so these tools are also
on board the international space station
wow
today trainers in brampton work
alongside flight controllers in montreal
and astronauts in houston all
interacting with the same space station
hi susan
hi
her colleagues appear as avatars
basically floating heads that mimic
their actual movements
you get that experience of like oh you
hear them right next to you on like this
side instead of like being on zoom and
people talking over one another and
cutting out this felt like a real
conversation mixed reality tech has been
adopted by a range of industries from
this paper mill in quebec to canada's
oldest candy company in new brunswick
when a piece of equipment at the ganong
factory breaks down the manufacturer
used to send someone often overseas but
in the pandemic they started connecting
and assisting virtually
in virtual reality it feels like you're
looking under the hood of a car but
under the hood of our hardware and
looking at all of like our mechanisms
while they're moving
is is pretty incredible
businesses are also deploying new
technology to limit infection in the
workplace moving beyond plexiglas to
airborne pathogen detection systems
employees will return to the office if
they feel safe
they have to feel safe and comfortable
so much has changed in such a short time
but what happens when the pandemic
finally ends is there any going back to
the way it was before i think work has
changed permanently
i think that some form of hybrid will be
the norm and hybrid will mean different
things to different employers
if employers don't adapt owl warrants
employees will vote with their feet
or in mansur's case they're sails
[Music]
we're really going
[Music]
when winter comes mansour may give up
the boat but he says he'll never return
to a traditional office job
i enjoy the freedom of being able to
work from different places new horizons
have opened so i think we will chase
those
[Music]